[Music]
Smart Cover the ball Jesus young Santa
[ __ ]
[Applause]
smart stepping up big angel tights goes
one way sets the screen no hesitation
it's clutch time it's Marcus smart time
and he has something to satisfy
Gourevitch said yes I am Marcus smart
and I baked these guys
I heard a will inbound
41.7 full shot-clock available here
[Applause]
yo he would jumps out on quickly young
takes it to the basket SATs loader does
not
[Applause]
108 106
[Music]
parks do not need to foul
[Applause]
nice
looking for Haywood back door nearly
picked off this barn again gets in the
paint a couple of fakes lost the handle
[Applause]
here comes young those don't have a foul
to give watch out to the three there it
goes
[Applause]
now the question would be
did young raise the leg to trip smart is
that what that whole thing I don't know
but let's go back to the defense by
clicking Daniel theis moving his feet
there's the space this long outstretched
arms now here's where it gets a little
crazy
does he know no he doesn't
so it's kind of like two things going on
here bike you have the player stepping
over the player which is obviously a
deal in the NBA right it's a big deal
whatever reason they draw a line at that
right then the other one is you have
Trey young sort of pushing him like you
aren't allowed to step over V so
I think they're just gonna call a foul
entre own not gonna be a tech but just
move it and sing all along and I think
that is the right way to do it this
[Music]
sells with nine steals and seven blocked
shots as we look at so make the game
numbers about to go by
[Applause]
two-point game
[Applause]
tennis is for young 9 - smart
so explain this game without Kemba
Walker down with the flu
[Applause]